[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce qu'il souhaitait que toute chose
sus bonne et qu'il n'y ait dans la
mesure du possible rien d'un parfait le
démiurge se saisit de tout ce qui était
visible et la menace du désordre à
l'ordre estimant que l'ordre va l'être
infiniment mieux que le désordre
ces quelques phrases sont extraites du
team et le grand récit cosmologique de
platon qui suivant l'aveu propres de
l'auteur ne peut qu'être vraisemblable
parce que quand il s'agit de
s'intéresser à l'origine de l'univers ou
à la structure du cosmos bien évidemment
il faut demeurer humble et modeste mais
je crois que ce qui se signent ici avant
tout c'est notre étonnante passion pour
les mythes de lin et de l'ordre ou
peut-être plutôt notre phobie récurrente
du multiple et du chaos
on le voit dès la religion veda ou pour
tenter de supprimer ou transcender les
singularités et multiplicité locale il
est recouru à un frein this principe
unique transcendant régulateur qui
permet de révéler l'ontologie
c'est-à-dire l'être en tant qu'être du
réel de façon incongrue rabelais
beaucoup plus tard on le voit avec lao
tseu et le tao où là encore et de façon
peut-être plus extrêmes ont recours à
l'unicité régulatrice comme dans une
sorte d'implosion commune yaël des
puissances cosmogonique elle même on le
voit en egypte où c'est le dieu amon ra
qui s'impose comme divinités tutélaires
comme pour conjurer le foisonnement des
immortels et donc accéder à l'unité et
en afrique de l'ouest
on le voit avec la cosmologie des dogon
ou c'est le dieu amma qui s'impose en
ceci qu'il chope aux aogo le renard pâle
le fauteur de troubles l'incarnation
donc du chaos dans le domaine de la
métaphysique occidentale
je dirais que l'ordre est le nom même de
la pensée l'ordre théologique c'est à
dire religieux l'ordre téléologique
c'est-à-dire finalistes l'ordre
nécessaire ou l'ordre contingent ils
constituent la colonne vertébrale de
notre histoire philosophique et le fait
est que ce désir d'unicité et de
taxinomie est effectivement à l'oeuvre
dans le domaine des sciences et en
particulier des sciences de la nature
qu'on pense par exemple à isaac newton
le père de tous les physiciens il opère
une incroyable mise en ordre comprendre
que la chute d'un fruit dans un verger
et le mouvement des corps célestes
proviennent fondamentalement des mêmes
lois c'est à la fois une découverte
sidérante de beauté est presque
émouvante d'efficacité qu'on pense à
albert einstein peut être moins connus
pour cela mais qui est aussi un
unificateur
finalement ce qu'il prouve ce qui le met
en exergue c'est pourrait-on dire la
similitude entre le contenant et le
contenu c'est à dire entre l'espace
temps et les objets les champs physique
et qu'on pense enfin à la physique des
particules élémentaires qui montre que
l'électricité et le magnétisme ne sont
que deux apparences d'un même phénomène
sous jacent l'électromagnétisme et que
l'éléctromagnétisme et la force
nucléaire faible ne sont que deux
apparences d'un même phénomène sous
jacent la force électrofaible
incontestablement l'histoire et pour le
meilleur de la science de la nature a
été structurée par ce désir d'unité et
d'affrontement du chaos
pourtant et c'est probablement la raison
de ma présence ici aujourd'hui
j'aimerais nous proposer une vision à
contre courant une vision si ce n'est
hétérodoxes peut être moins originale
d'un rapport que la science pourrait
avoir avec le multiple et le désordre
regardons d'abord les phénomènes ce que
la physique nous apprend depuis quelques
décennies
ce n'est pas l'unité et finalement ce
qu'elle nous montre c'est une incroyable
diversité des objets qui se trouvent
dans l'univers aussi bien au très grand
échelle le macrocosme très petite
échelle le microcosme co dg
l'intermédiaire un simple tas de sable
est un abîme de complexité le sable peut
exister à l'état liquide solide ou
gazeux suivant les circonstances est un
subtil réseau de contraintes un peu
formée des architectures envoûte ou en
tunnel le sable est tout sauf simple
mais plus profondément encore pensons à
la multiplicité des lois aujourd'hui la
grande unification poursuite de la
démarche que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
eshu la manière mathématiquement la plus
simple de la mettre en oeuvre et d'ores
et déjà invalidé par l'expérience la
supersymétrie qui tentait de mettre sur
un pied d'égalité les forces les objets
les interactions et les choses
elle était un des point nodal des études
menées au grand collisionneur de hadrons
du cern est à ce jour non découvertes
pour tenter d'expliquer l'accélération
de l'univers ont recours à ce qu'on
nomme un champ de quinte et sens
c'est-à-dire nouvelle force le contraire
d'une unification et enfin la fameuse
quoique très spéculative théorie des
cordes semble faire apparaître un
paysage donc une sorte de méta diversité
de loi physique possible même les
régulateurs semblent être comme infectés
par le nombreux et le contingent plus
profondément encore pensons un instant à
la prédictibilité on le sait aujourd'hui
et depuis longtemps d'ailleurs il y à
des systèmes chaotique
c'est à dire pour lesquelles la
connaissance des conditions initiales ne
permet pas concrètement de trouver
l'état final parce qu'une divergence
infime dans les circonstances primitive
donnera lieu un état final drastiquement
différents ils sont prédictible endroit
mais ils ne le sont pas on fait qu'on
pense aussi à la mécanique quantique
vous savez cette science qui décrit
l'infiniment petit le monde quantique
est pourrait-on dire aléatoire par s
ans il y à une perte de prédictibilité
qui n'est pas associée à notre
incompétence mais qui semble être une
caractéristique intrinsèque de la nature
est aujourd'hui de façon spéculative
mais intéressante
il semble même émergé des systèmes
classiques non quantique non chaotique
pour lesquels il y à perte de
déterminisme dans les trous noirs par
exemple il semble exister un horizon
interne nommé horizon de kochi au delà
duquel la trajectoire d'un astronaute
imprudents qui tenteraient de
s'aventurer n'est plus prédictibles même
si je sais d'où je viens je ne peux pas
savoir où j'irai et ça si c'est avéré
c'est une forme de révolution
notre dans notre manière d'appréhender
de concevoir et de poser la projection
futur d'une trajectoire d'un mètre
pourrait-on dire à notre environnement
à partir d'une théorie physique plus
profondément encore j'aimerais que nous
interrogions aujourd'hui la multiplicité
des mondes
vous savez peut-être que le concept de
multivers multi univers fait aujourd'hui
effraction dans le domaine de la science
physique
ce n'est pas une élucubration haddock
arbitraire qui émerge par goût désir de
multiplicité ou peut-être par perversion
de subversion non c'est une conséquence
de certaines de nos théories bien
comprise
il se pourrait que même notre monde soit
à relativiser comme un îlot dérisoire et
contingents dans ce vaste de plus rivère
peut-être faut-il apprendre à penser
avec cette nuée cotonneuse de
propositions physique
à ce propos ou peut-être pas tout à fait
à ce propos le poète antonin artaud
écrivait d'ailleurs que l'enveloppement
contenu du bruit avait l'instance obscur
et la pénétration d'un regard vivants
oui
l'espace rendait son plein coton mental
on ne le pensait encore n'était net et
ne restituaient sa décharge objets mais
peu à peu la masse tourna comme une
espèce d'immense influent de 100 végétal
étonnant et les radicelles qui vibrait à
la lisière de mon oeil mental je détache
heures avec une vitesse de vertige
de la masse crispé du vent et tout
l'espace trembla comme un sexe que le
globe ardent du ciel saccageaient
quelque chose du bec d'une colombe et l3
la masse confuse des états peut-être
faut-il apprendre à penser avec cette
masse confuse qui n'est pas
nécessairement un nihilisme épistémique
ce que j'aimerais nous propose et c'est
à la fois ma conclusion est le message
principal que je voulais suggéré ce soir
plus fondamentalement encore c'est que
la physique pourrait avoir je le dis de
façon non doctrinal et dogmatique je le
dis à titre expérimental comme une
hypothèse pourrait avoir donc partie
liée avec le multiple et le désordre de
façon sémantique ou syntaxique en son
coeur même de façon pourrait-on dire
structurelles regardez ne pensons pas à
la science aussi fier aux modèles déjà
falsifiés mais vraiment au meilleur
théorie dont on dispose à l'heure
actuelle celle qui tente doute repasser
ce que l'on sait tels qu'ils sont
candidates à une description meilleur à
l'avènement d'une nouvelle science par
exemple la gravitation quantique une
sorte de graal de la physique théorique
depuis près d'un siècle
aujourd'hui c'est une dizaine de modèles
concurrents qui tente de faire face à
cette question la vision orthodoxe
consiste à supposer que le temps passant
les théories fausses seront élagués
falsifiés par les observations et que
demeurera la bonne théorie mais je crois
que cette vision est caricatural au
point d'être franchement fausse
franchement fauche parce que d'abord le
nombre de théories concurrentes ne
diminue pas avec le temps parce qu'au
fur et à mesure que des théories sont
effectivement élaguer falsifiés par
l'expérience d'autres théories sont
inventés et le fait est que la structure
de la pensée scientifique n'est pas
pyramidale est plutôt trapézoïdale
s'écartant parce qu'on invente plus de
théorie qu'on en fait si fille on ne
convergent pas c'est un fait
sociologique vers l'unité
ensuite parce que la bonne théorie mais
on ne l'a pas on n'a jamais eu dans le
passé
ce serait une prétention outre
puis dante que de croire que justement
là maintenant pendant cet exposé nous
disposons de la théorie ultime
jamais elle n'a été à notre disposition
je ne sais même pas si elle existe je ne
sais même pas si la nature est un
endroit descriptible parfaitement en
termes physiques aux mathématiques et
quand bien même elle existerait on ne
s'en approchent pas puisque chaque
révolution épistémologique et
pourrait-on dire infiniment distante de
la précédente et de la suivante
pour toutes ces raisons je crois
peut-être à contre-courant de la doxa
que ce que la physique nous dit c'est
précisément que le monde et cette
multiplicité de modèles qui sont
simultanément juste quoique mutuellement
exclusifs exclusif parce qu'ils nous
disent pas la même chose
mais simultanément vrai au sens
scientifique du terme pas si vous voulez
dans cette visée à l'éthique global avec
un grand v de vérité mais qu'ils sont
vrais parce qu'ils sont à un instant
donné compatible avec les mesures
mathématiquement cohérent et étudier
disons par une communauté raisonnable de
d'experts raisonnablement compétents
voilà ce qui fait la véridicité
scientifique ce que je nous propose
c'est de considérer cet état de fait non
pas comme transitoire et pourrait-on
dire dijon ctif mais comme permanent
parce qu'il en a toujours été comme ça
et que je parais qui l'on sera toujours
comme ça et conjonctif penser cette
multiplicité comme étant le coeur parce
que c'est le cas de la proposition
scientifiques sur le réel
bien sûr cette permanence évolué mais
structurellement elle demeure me
semble-t-il relativement égale à elle
même et vous le voyez sans rien travesti
du geste scientifique
c'est une forme de multiplicité
relativement chaotique qui ça paraît si
on la considère avec sérieux et me
semble-t-il avec parcimonie il y a
quelques mois je t'ai mandatée par le
haut-commissariat à l'évaluation de la
recherche de l'enseignement supérieur a
statué avec quelques collègues bien sûr
sur les travaux d'un des meilleurs
laboratoires de physique théorique en
france et j'ai été intéressé pour ne pas
dire ému que le fondateur de ce
laboratoire
prononce lors de son discours inaugural
qui nous étaient retransmis quelques
décennies plus tard les mots suivants la
physique théorique à son plus haut
niveau exige 10 est il des esprits
bizarre et même poursuivre at il des
esprits en bible je crois qu'il faut
oser penser avec cette ambiguïté c'est
vraisemblablement une nécessité logique
c'est probablement une ouverture éthique
c'est sans aucun doute un prolongement
esthétique et poétique poétique
évidemment au chant soul antonelle où
l'entendait là encore antonin artaud
sous la poésie des textes je veux dire
est il la poésie nu sans forme et son
texte
merci
[Applaudissements]